so that place that we talked about that
interconnected so the essence of
masculine practice as I teach it and
this is how I teach men is to connect to
to tether to the part of you that is
infinite and unchanging and then use
breath and use your body to use breath
to ground and open your body and from
there move from there kiss her from
there you know you know start a sexual
moment from there you know lead her into
the bedroom that's that's a difference
that sounds esoteric but you can feel it
and if I put you in if I if I did that
in front of a roomful of women they
would feel it and and so that's what we
do at workshops right it's become so
obvious when you actually see it you're
like okay would you trust this more
right so would you for the feminine for
your feminine for you to surrender your
heart deeply and fully to the man you
love you have to trust him not just in
life but moment to moment right so not
only have to trust him as he leads his
life in your life but in the moment you
have to trust them in the moment there's
a you're looking for that solidity
you're looking for and now this can
switch they can't like he could be an
effeminate eek and completely he could
be a hot mess
might not know what to do not have
anywhere to go like baby I don't know
what to do you lead us tonight I've been
working all weekend I've been you know
mean like and it can switch and it can
become a very beautiful moment that way
but by and large most men and women
still fall into these lines if your
feminine essence you want to trust your
masculine partner completely and to do
that he has to have a trust of all
structure which is his body and his
breath and his awareness that's
structure that he's dressing or one that
you know well both both like you could
feel it right so if so if we take a
moment right cuz you said like let's
talk about the sexual moment so let's
just take a moment like
you're in the kitchen and you're making
dinner and your husband walks in and and
and he walks in he skips he's skipping
walking in because he's just so happy
about something or he's like really
excited about something chances of that
turning into a sexual moment probably
not great but if he walks in like we
talked about very solid connected to
this core of himself like literally
where you could like he walks in and you
feel depth it's a nerve you feel it in
your nervous system and your nervous
system can then like all like wow he's
[ __ ] solid right now and maybe he
steps behind you and he takes a breath
with you eat has now created a structure
with his body his breath and his
awareness for you to relax into that now
if in that moment it feels good and you
sigh you've now brought energy to his
structure like if if he comes behind you
and he takes a deep breath and he puts
his arms or on you know like on either
side of you he creates this structure
I'm just giving one millions of examples
and he breathes with you and feels good
and you sigh and kind of just snuggle
into him you give an energy to that
moment he's brought structure
you've brought energy now you're in a
polarized moment and so the more energy
you bring and the more depth and
structure he brings the deeper the
polarity that can be created and we have
what's known as you know really the
beautiful set
you
[Music]